Và Pauli Chico, đưa tình Mỹ, bà lý mình tròo ấy, u đang sử dựa một kế hoạch hiện vợp.
Nhà môi đồng khoảng 30,000 tỉ đúng là Mỹ từ vồn bốn công và tư để hỗ trợ tại thiết u cuy nghe,
sau khi nghe chăm dích chính xếp quân sự quân một lớn, kế hoạch đưa tỉ giệm chức tại liệu dài người tám chân,
bây giờ lộ chính phục poy kéo sai mười năm, đồng thời tạo điều kiện để u cuy nghe từng bước tình tới tư cất tình tin ấyu.
Theo các quân trước ấyu, Bruce and Spaw Quá Trinh tình đang thuộc đầy thực tâm kếc tại chính xài hạn,
đồng thời khoảng 30,000 tỉ đồng từ trong tự lài, tuy nhiên kế hoạch thục thuộc nhiều và khá lăn đại được lạnh yên bắn,
trong bối kánh giang chẳng bản thịp diễn, kế hoạch hiện vợp là một phân trước sang kế hoạc biên gồm,
hà mi điểm giò Mỹ thuộc đầy tập chung và phục hồi kinh tế, thay bị lộ chính quân sự.
Cùng thuy điểm có khu đàn phản phà biên giữa ngà, u cuy ngà và Mỹ diễn ra tại uài,
các quân tiếp xúc giữa tổng thống buc chiên và đặt phay viên Mỹ cũng như của tiếp xúc Mỹ,
hôm quân ai tại dễ đàn đà vôs, cho thay những nỗ lần ngoại sáng dùm giúp để tìm tiếm giải phát triển trí cho cuộc súng độc kếm xài ngăn bộ năm.